My name is Joe Cheng.
I am the CTO of Posit.
Most days I co-lead the Shiny
team with Winston Chang.
Shiny really started
with the request
from one of our users, one of
our earliest users of RStudio IDE.
Professor Danny Kaplan asked
us for an interactive way
to present statistical and
math concepts to students,
and he knew R really well.
So he wanted to do it in R.
So it wasn't
until probably a year
after he had made this
request that I stumbled
onto a technology called Meteor
that was pushing this new to me
very alien form of programming
called reactive programming.
And it took me a while to get
my head around how it actually
worked and a little digging
through their source code.
But finally, after I
understood what they were doing
and some time had passed where
I guess my brain could marinate in
it, I woke up one morning and
I just had this vision of HTML
with no JavaScript in it,
just simple markup that
had indicators of what
elements were inputs
and what elements were outputs.
Combine that with
reactive code written
in R that would power
that HTML interface
and tie it all together
with a WebSocket connection.
It really felt like
this could be a way
to build applications that
were interactive enough
to satisfy the needs of not
just Danny, but a lot of Dannys
out there in the R world.
And I think Shiny will always
find its purest expression in R
just because of how
flexible the language is.
But it's impossible to
ignore how many people
could benefit if we bring those
same ideas to Python as well.
The design of the
language really
prioritizes ease
of understanding
and ease of reading.
Whereas, I think in R we tend
to favor a concise expression
of our ideas, and maybe a
certain elegance and symmetry.
And in Python, readability,
understandability, simplicity,
those are valued more. So
I think, for some people,
Python is just home.
I mean, it's famously the second
best language for anything,
right?
I think that's the
label that Pythonistas
probably wear with pride.
And because Python is the second
best language for anything,
it means that if we want to
reach more people with Shiny,
we can reach all those people
for whom Python is useful.
And that's a lot of people.